[Musique]
c'est magnifique fils parfait mais
inutile
j'ai quelque chose pour toi diego dans
des mains papa écoute une grenade c'est
très simple elle a quatre pièces
essentielles le corps qui contient
l'explosif le détonateur le levier est
bien sûr d'abord pee
qu'est ce que tu fais respire 10go
respire la goupille ne sert qu'à
maintenir le levier en place ce n'est
que lorsque tu le lâchera cas cette
grenade fera suis moi maintenant
[Musique]
je suis el presidente ce qui veut dire
qu'un jour à ton tour tu seras elle
préside à noter notre peuple
ils ne savent pas comment être heureux
ils sont divisés valabre indécision
oppositions sont étouffés par leur
propre liberté
même si tu as le coeur rempli d'amour
même si tu veux le meilleur pour eux
même si tu cherches à les sauver
2 à iron diego tout ce que tu diras fera
pensera sera forcément mauvais
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il te répondront par des hurlements
[Musique]
diront que tu es le diable
que tuer un monstre
et ils offriront
[Applaudissements]
ceux ci
[Musique]
alors dit moi et tu le diable
tu un monstre up
parce que notre pays est comme cette
grenade sauf qu'il n'est composée que de
deux parties essentielles
notre peuple
et toi
et toi tu dois les tenir
bien fermement ou alors nous avons
tout ce faire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tu vas te compris maintenant
comble